- [Voiceover] This episode
of CC Social Scene is based
on your suggestions for
the worst vacation rental.
- [Voiceover] It
was supposed to be
a romantic summer getaway.
- Honey, what would
you say about staying
at this rental property?
- [Woman] I'd say that
place is perfect, dear.
- Oh, here are our lovely hosts.
- Wayne and Shari.
Oh they do look lovely.
- [Voiceover] They
thought they would have
the best trip ever.
They were wrong.
(door creaks)
(eerie music)
(heartbeat)
- Hello?
Are they still here?
(thunder)
- No smoking, no
parties, no old people.
- Enjoy the house, just
don't go in that closet
because there's
nothing in there.
(cackles)
- Oh, also the shower
is broken, sorry.
You can take a splash bath
if you get some water
from the toilet.
- If you guys need anything
we'll be at my brothers,
so, uh, give us a jingle.
- [Wayne] Have a great
time in the house.
- Take care.
- [Woman] Take care.
- [Voiceover] If something
seems too good to be true,
it probably is.
- Ski boots.
(eerie music)
(door creaks)
(toy squeak)
- [Voiceover] What do you
do when you need to get away
from your getaway?
(rodents squeak)
(lock clicks)
(eerie music)
- S'up?
Her bro kicked us out.
I guess he doesn't like pranks.
- Looks like we're going to
have to crash with you guys.
(sniffs)
- Did somebody open the closet?
- Hey, uh, ya wanna make out?
- Oh, no, no thanks.
- Prude.
- [Voiceover] This
summer, remember to think
before you click.
(thunder)
- Honey.
Honey, my jacket.
(snores)
- Hey!
Where you guys going?
- You still have
three days left.
- Um, Vanessa's
actually having, uh,
- a baby.
- [Vanessa] A baby.
- [Vanessa] We have to
go to the doctor and um,
he's ordered a car.
- Oh, he's here.
(phone chimes)
- Oh, I just got a fare.
- [Shari] Cool.
(eerie music)
- [Voiceover] Bummer Rental.
You'll need a vacation
from this vacation.
- Relax guys, the maid
will be here any minute.
- Oh.
[Vanessa] Oh.
- [Shari] Oh, there she is.
- [Voiceover] Join
the conversation now
with CC Social Scene.
Give us your tips on how
to take the perfect
profile picture
and might write it
into our next sketch.
Presented by Redd's Apple
Ale, pick different.